here are the best and worst outcomes of
the midterm elections the best Jerry the
best even the Republican stalwarts at
Fox News agree that the GOP take over
the Senate was a protest vote against
President Obama has failed Democratic
policies not an endorsement of Mitch
McConnell in the Republican agenda it's
always good to see politicians held
accountable the best Jerry the best
voters in Alaska Oregon in Washington DC
legalized recreational marijuana dealing
yet another body blow to the war on
drugs a majority in Florida backed
medical marijuana but the initiative
fell short of the 60 percent necessary
for legalization the best Jerry the best
Democrat Gina Raimondo became governor
of Rhode Island despite being opposed by
public sector unions for her central
rolling raining in out-of-control
pension plans Republican Governor Scott
Walker in Wisconsin and rick Snyder and
Michigan were reelected despite their
taking on public sector unions as well
the worst Jam voters in four states
approved hikes in the minimum wage
whatever the intentions might be making
workers more expensive by legislative
Fiat will only make it that much harder
for the most unskilled people to find
jobs the worst Jerry the People's
Republic of Berkeley overwhelmingly
passed the country's first real sin tax
on soda the tax will increase the cost
of a 20-ounce soda by ten percent the
worst Jam the bipartisan Budget
agreement reached earlier this year
increased spending levels beyond
sequestration and while many of the new
Republican senators were vague about
what programs they would cut while
campaigning they all pledged to support
extra defense spending and to protect
and preserve Social Security and
Medicare that almost certainly means
spending hikes over the next two years
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie